two points of
two of the points that define a certain
quadrilateral are negative four comma
negative two so let's plot that so
that's negative four
comma negative two
and zero comma five
and zero comma five so that's zero comma
five right over there the quadrilateral
is left
unchanged by a reflection over the line
y is equal to x over two so what does
that line look like
y is equal to x over 2. i'll do that in
blue
y is equal to x over 2. so when x is
equal to 0 y is 0. the y-intercept is 0
here and the slope is one-half every
time x increases by one y will increase
by one half or when x increases by two y
will increase by one so x increases by
two y increases by one x is increasing
by increases by two y is equal
y increases by one another way to think
about it y is always one half of x when
x is four y is two when x is six
y is three when x is eight y is four so
we could connect these let me try my
best
attempt to draw these in a relatively
straight line and then i could keep
going
when x is negative 2 y is negative 1
when x is negative 4 y is negative 2. so
it actually goes through that point
right there and it just keeps going with
a slope of one-half so this line and i
can draw it a little bit thicker now now
that i've dotted it out
this is the line
y is equal to x over two
and they also say that the quadrilateral
is left unchanged by reflection over the
line
over the line y is equal to negative two
x plus five so the y intercept here is
five when x is zero y is five so it
actually goes through that point and the
slope is negative two every time we
increase by 1 our every time we increase
x by 1 we decrease y by 2. so that's so
we go there we go there
and we keep going at a slope of
negative 2. so it's going to look
something like this it's going to look
something
something like this it actually goes to
that point and just keeps going on and
on so
this is my
best attempt at drawing
that line so that is y
is equal to negative 2x plus 5.
now let's think about let's see if we
can draw this quadrilateral
so let's first reflect the quadrilateral
or let's reflect the points we have over
the line y is equal to x over 2. so this
is the line y is equal to x over 2. this
magenta point the point negative 4 2 is
already on that line so if you it's its
own reflection i guess you could say
it's on the mirror one way one way is to
think about it but we can easily reflect
this line over here
this line if we were to drop a
perpendicular if we were to drop a
perpendicular
we'd drop it perpendicular and actually
this line right over here y is equal to
negative 2x plus 5 is perpendicular to y
is equal to x over 2. how do we know
well if one if you have a if one line
has a slope of m then the line that's
perpendicular would be the negative
reciprocal of this it would be negative
one over m
so this first line has a slope of
one-half
well what's the negative reciprocal of
one-half well the reciprocal of one-half
is two over one and you make that
negative so it is equal to negative two
so this slope is a negative reciprocal
of this slope so these lines are indeed
these lines are indeed i'm trying to
erase that these lines are indeed
perpendicular so we literally could drop
a perpendicular literally go along this
line right over here in our attempt to
reflect and we see that we're going kind
of down
down 2 over 1 down 2 over 1 twice so
let's go down 2 over 1 down 2 over 1
twice again the reflection let me do
that in that same color the reflection
of this point
across y is equal to x over 2 is this
point right over there so now we have
three points of our quadrilateral let's
see if we can get a fourth so let's go
to the magenta point the magenta point
we've already seen it's kind of it's
it's it's sitting on top of y equals x
over two so trying to reflect it doesn't
help us much but we could try to reflect
it across y is equal to negative 2x plus
5.
so once again these lines are
perpendicular to each other actually let
me mark that off these lines are
perpendicular so we can drop a
perpendicular and try to find its
reflection so we're going to the right
two and up one we're doing that once
twice three times on the left side so
let's do that once twice three times on
the right side so the reflection is
right there we essentially want to go to
that line and however far we were to
kind of the left of it we want to go
that same that bottom left direction we
want to go in the same direction to the
top right the same distance to get the
reflection
so there you have it there is our
there is our other point so now we have
the four points of
four points of this quadrilateral four
points of this quadrilateral
are
they are
or the four side let me actually just
draw the quadrilateral we have our four
points so this is one side right over
here
this is one side
right over here this is another side
right over here
and you can verify that these are
parallel how would you verify that
they're parallel well they have the same
slope if you get from this point to that
point you have to go over so your run
has to be four and you have to rise one
two three four five six seven so the
slope here is seven fourths so slope
here rise over run or change in y over
change in x is seven fourths and over
here you go one two three four so you
run four and then you rise one two three
four five six seven so the slope here is
also seven over four so these two lines
these two lines are going to be
these two lines are going to be parallel
and then we could draw these lines over
here
these lines over here
so this one at the top
the one at the top right over there
and what's its slope well let's see we
go from x equals zero to x equals eight
so we go down our change in y is
negative one every time we
increase x by eight so this is a slope
of slope
is equal to negative one over eight and
that's the exact same slope that we have
right over here negative one over eight
so these two lines are parallel as well
this line
is parallel to this line as well
so at minimum we're dealing with a
parallelogram let's see if we can get
even more specific because this kind of
looks like a rhombus it looks like a
parallelogram where all four sides have
the same length
so there's a couple of ways that you
could verify that this parallelogram is
a rhombus one way is you could actually
find the distance between the points you
could use that we know the coordinates
so you could use the distance formula
which really comes straight out of the
pythagorean theorem or even better you
can look at the diagonals of this
rhombus
you can look at the diagonals of this
parallelogram we're trying to figure out
if it's rhombus and if the diagonals are
perpendicular then you're dealing with a
rhombus and we've already shown that
these diagonals that this diagonal
this diagonal and this diagonal are
perpendicular are perpendicular they
intersect at right angles and so this
must be a rhombus